these fellow Scholars this is two minute
papers with Dr Carol Jonah ifahir today
we are going to clone real human voices
using an AI how well in an earlier
Nvidia keynote we had a look at Jensen
Jr an ai-powered virtual assistant of
Nvidia CEO and Jensen Huang it could do
this synthetic biology is about
designing biological systems at multiple
levels from Individual molecules look at
the face of that proud man I love how it
also uses hand gestures that go really
well with the explanation this virtual
AI assistants are going to appear
everywhere to help you with your daily
tasks for instance in your car the
promise is that they will be able to
recognize you as the owner of the car
recommend shows nearby and even drive
you there these Omniverse avatars may
also help us order our favorite Burgers
too and we won't even need to push
buttons on a touchscreen we just need to
say what we wish to eat and the
assistant will answer and take our
orders perhaps later even in a familiar
person's voice how cool is that and
today I am going to ask you to imagine a
future where we can all have our toy
Johnsons or our own virtual assistants
with our own voice all of us that sounds
really cool so is that in the far future
no no not at all today I have the
amazing opportunity to show you a bit
more about the AI that makes this voice
synthesis happen and yes you will hear
things that are only available here at
two minute papers so what is all this
about this work is an AI based technique
that takes samples of our voice and can
then clone it let's give it a try this
is Jameel from Nvidia who was kind
enough to record these voice Snippets
listen I think they have to change that
further details are expected later
okay so how much of this do we need to
train the AI well not the entire live
recordings of the test subject but much
less only 30 minutes of these voice
samples the technique asks us to say
these sentences and analyzes the Timbre
prosody and the rhythm of our voice
which is quite a task and what can it do
afterwards well hold on to your papers
because Jamil not the real one the Clone
AI Jamil has a scholarly message for you
that I wrote this is a voice line
generated by an AI wonder if you fellow
Scholars are going to notice the first
law of paper says that research is a
process do not look at where we are look
at where we will be two more papers down
the line the Third Law of paper says
that a bad researcher fails 100 of the
time while a good one only fails 99 of
the time hence what you see here is
always just one percent the work that
was done so what do you think about
these voice lines are they real or are
they synthesized now of course it is not
perfect I think that most of you are
able to tell that these voice lines were
synthesized but my opinion is that these
are easily good enough for a helpful
human-like virtual assistant and really
how cool is that cloning a human voice
from half an hour worth of sound samples
what a time to be alive and note that I
have been really tough with them these
are some long scholarly sentences that
would give a challenge to any of these
algorithms now if you are one of our
earlier fellow Scholars you might
remember that a few years ago we talked
about an AI technique called tacotron
which can perform voice cloning from a
really short few second long sample I
have only heard of simple shorter
sentences for that and what is new here
is that this new technique takes more
data but in return offers higher quality
but it doesn't stop there it does even
more this new method is easier to train
and it also generalizes to more
languages better and these are already
good enough to be used in real products
so I wonder what a technique like this
will look like just two more papers down
the line maybe my voice here on two
minute papers could be synthesized by an
AI maybe it already is would that be a
good thing what do you think also a
virtual calorie for you to read your
daily dose of papers hmm actually since
Nvidia has a great track record of
putting these amazing tools into
everyone's hands if you are interested
there is already An Early Access program
where you can apply I hope that some of
you will be able to try this and let us
know in the comments below this episode
has been supported by coheir AI kohir
builds large language models and makes
them available through an API so
businesses can add Advanced language
understanding to their system or app
quickly with just one line of code you
can use your own data whether it's text
from customer service requests legal
contracts or social media posts to
create your own custom models to
understand text or even generated
for instance it can be used to
automatically determine whether your
messages are about your business hours
returns or shipping or it can be used to
generate a list of possible sentences
you can use for your product
descriptions make sure to go to
cohere.ai papers or click the link in
the video description and give it a try
today it's super easy to use thanks for
watching and for your generous support
and I'll see you next time